comme tous les vendredis votre magazine
pour analyser la propagande de Vladimir
Poutine sur fond de guerre en Ukraine et
qui dit vide aussi dit et les navoloshin
bonjour Elena bonjour Florent vous allez
bien sûr revenir sur l'actualité de la
semaine en Russie c'est évidemment cette
attaque de drone survenu sur le Kremlin
dans la nuit du 2 au 3 mai et vous allez
nous raconter comment elle a été vécue
justement comment elle était vue de
Russie oui il est un peu plus de 14h30 à
Moscou ce mercredi 3 mai donc lorsque le
Kremlin publie un communiqué qui annonce
cette attaque pas de dégâts matériels ni
de victimes dit se communiquer un peu
plus tôt déjà on commençait à voir sur
les réseaux sociaux et sur les chaînes
de télévision russe à des images filmées
par les résidents du quartier et les
caméras de vidéosurveillance celles que
vous voyez notamment à l'écran avec ce
drone qui vole et qui est abattu au
dessus de la coupole du Palais des
Sénats au Kremlin le soir même
l'événement il fait évidemment la une
des journaux télévisés regardez un
extrait du journal de la chaîne Rossiya
1 l'une des deux principales chaînes du
pays
le régime de Kiev a tenté de frapper le
Kremlin c'est ce qu'a annoncé
aujourd'hui le service de presse du
président la résidence du chef de l'État
était la cible de deux drones que les
militaires et les services de sécurité
ont pu neutraliser avec succès
l'événement est qualifié d'attaque
terroriste et de tentative d'homicide
sur le président le chef du Parlement
russe a déclaré que l'attentat
terroriste contre le président c'est une
attaque contre la Russie et que le
régime nazi de Kiev doit être déclaré
comme organisation terroriste c'est la
première fois que le Kremlin fait
l'objet d'une attaque depuis la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et donc avant même
qu'une enquête officielle ne soit donc
officiellement ouverte les chaînes de
télévision on l'a vu les officiels
russes imputent cette attaque à ceux qui
qualifient de nazis et de terroristes en
Ukraine oui ce sont en fait les termes
génériques qui sont employés par les la
propagande et par les dirigeants russes
pour qualifier les dirigeants Ukrainiens
parce qu'il justifie en permanence cette
guerre de conquête de l'Ukraine de
Vladimir Poutine par une croisade contre
le mal c'est encore le cas encore plus à
la veille des célébrations du 9 mai
cette grande fête de la victoire en
Russie où l'on célèbre la victoire de
l'Union soviétique contre l'Allemagne
nazie alors les chaînes de télévision
russe elles en profitent pour jouer la
surenchère dans le parallèle entre la
grande guerre patriotique et celle que
la Russie mènerait aujourd'hui pour la
défense de sa patrie en Ukraine écouter
ce soir-là le 3 mai donc le célèbre
propagandiste russe Vladimir soloviop ce
qu'il dit dans son émission quotidienne
la dernière fois c'était la magnésie qui
avait attaqué essayé de frapper le
Kremlin aujourd'hui c'est l'Ukraine nazi
ukrainiens ont commis une tentative
d'homicide contre le commandant en chef
de notre pays
et comme la propagande russe elle forge
dans la conscience collective russe
l'image d'un ennemi nazi et terroriste à
anéantir toutes les comparaisons sont
finalement bonnes affaires y compris
avec l'attentat du 11 septembre 2001
contre les tours jumelles à New York
celle du World Trade Center avec un
message ce n'est pas la Russie qui
aurait déclaré la guerre à l'Ukraine
mais bien l'Ukraine qui aurait déclaré
la guerre à la Russie écoutez cette
autre extrait d'un débat d'actualité sur
l'autre grande chaîne étatique russe
tous ces événements nous montrent que
l'Ukraine et non seulement bel et bien
un état terroriste
mais aussi déclaré une guerre terroriste
contre la Russie le pauvre
si vous vous souvenez New York septembre
2001 c'est le même style
c'est le même style évidemment
ce style est indispensable avant tout
pour attirer l'attention dans le champ
informationnel une comparaison il a bien
sûr ordre de propos les attentats du
World Trade Center ayant été perpétrés
par le biais d'avion qui ont été
détournés par des terroristes d'Al-Qaïda
oui qui ont fait 2600 morts alors
combien même Florent au lendemain même
de cette attaque de drones contre le
Kremlin vu de Russie les coupables ils
sont tout trouvé et parmi les
officielles russes qui appellent à les
assassiner on trouve sans surprise
mitry-medef le chef adjoint du Conseil
de sécurité de la Fédération de Russie
regardez cette séquence
et hop salut
l'attentat terroriste d'aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix que celui
d'éliminer physiquement zelinsky et sa
clique et
doit être éliminé le but principal aura
été atteint lorsqu'il aura été éliminé
quand on me dit on élimine razelenski
mais il y en aura un autre on
l'éliminera aussi et le troisième et le
quatrième et le cinquième aussi il y
aura plus de volontaire point barre ils
ne doivent pas marcher sur cette terre
on les butera jusque dans les chiottes
et si on en lançait un missile Satan
sans charge nucléaire
juste un bon petit missile on prévient
nos collègues américains que ce ne sera
pas un tir nucléaire et au Reiki Ève de
la carte c'est ce qu'on appelle des
propos sans équivoque on les butera
jusque dans les chiottes une autre
référence avait à ce qui a pu déclarer
Vladimir Poutine en parlant des
tchétchène c'était lorsqu'il a lancé la
deuxième guerre de Tchétchénie c'est ça
oui l'autre sanglante qui a marqué sa
prise de pouvoir un épisode que s'est
invité que vous avez entendu chez
Vladimir soloviov et qui appelle à tuer
les dirigeants Ukrainiens il connaît
bien cet épisode André gurrulov puisque
il a servi en pardon en Tchétchénie
pendant cette deuxième guerre
aujourd'hui il est général lieutenant de
réserve il est aussi député du Parlement
russe et au lendemain de cette émission
durant laquelle il propose donc de punir
les coupables de l'attaque de drone
contre le Kremlin le Kremlin justement
en la personne de Mitry pescope le
porte-parole de Vladimir Poutine il
désigne d'autres coupables sans
toutefois apporter plus de preuves que
lors des premières accusations contre
l'Ukraine écoutez
nous savons très bien que les décisions
de tels actes de telles attentats
terroristes ne sont pas prises à Kiev
mais à Washington
ne fait qu'exécuter les ordres au début
des années 2000 lorsque nous combattuons
le terrorisme international en
Tchétchénie le président Poutine a
insisté à de multiples reprises auprès
de la communauté internationale les
appelant à cessé de subventionsner le
terrorisme international
on l'a compris selon la version
officielle russe sont donc les
Occidentaux qui subviançonneraient le
terrorisme international oui alors il
faut bien comprendre que cette
déclaration comme tant d'autres
lorsqu'il s'agit d'officiel russe elle
n'est pas là pour être discutée ou étayé
par des faits historiques il s'agit
simplement d'un sénère un dogme parmi
d'autres qui fondent le mythe de cette
guerre existentielle de la Russie pour
sa survie en l'occurrence cette
affirmation là elle participe à des
limitée un camp du mal que combat la
Russie ou les Occidentaux seraient de
mèches avec les terroristes qu'ils
soient tchétchen djihadistes ou
aujourd'hui
ukrainien finalement peu importe
problème pour le général André
gourioulov qui avait donc appelé dans
l'émission de soloviav à éliminer skill
s'est trompé de cible puisque Zelinski
il ne selon cette propagande que
l'exécutant des bases oeuvres de
Washington qu’importe le lendemain solov
le réinvite et du coup il trouve
d'autres solutions regardez
[Musique]
ceux qui reviennent de cubaine nous
disent les bases ont été stationnées les
troupes soviétiques sont toujours là en
parfait état et elle nous attendent du
coup je me pose la question pourquoi ne
crée-t-on pas des menaces qui feraient
atterrir les dirigeants politiques des
États-Unis d'Amérique la politesse
si on parle de sous-marin nucléaire
alors ils doivent camper en permanence
près des côtes américaines invisibles
ils doivent être comme des marmottes à
trembler que Dieu les en préserve ils
doivent être conscients du fait que leur
pays peut disparaître de la surface de
la terre
des menaces qui semblent irréalistes
mais rappelons tout de même tout de même
que la crise des missiles à Cuba entre
l'URSS d'un côté et les États-Unis de
l'autre avaient failli plonger le monde
au bord d'une guerre nucléaire oui en
1962 les États-Unis découvrent des
lampes de des rampes de lancement pardon
et des missiles nucléaires soviétiques
pointés vers eux à quelques 200 km de
leur côtes à Cuba donc pendant plusieurs
jours le temps que dure les négociations
entre Washington et Moscou le monde
retient son souffle finalement le RSS
accepte de retirer ses missiles en
échange de l'engagement américain de ne
pas envahir Cuba et de retirer ses
propres missiles nucléaires de Turquie
mais la question d'une potentiel frappe
nucléaire tactique de la Russie se pose
toujours elle est toujours en suspente
en tout cas oui en tout cas sur les
plateaux de télévision russe comme chez
soloviop on affirme que la guerre
nucléaire est inévitable en attendant ce
ne sont pas des missiles nucléaires mais
des missiles tout court qui pleuvent sur
l'Ukraine et parfois les propagandistes
russes il donne un coup de main pas
seulement pour mobiliser les esprits des
Russes derrière la guerre de Vladimir
Poutine regardez maintenant cette
séquence laspace prétendument dans la
région de l'ougance calamanov un
bataillon d'artilleur russe appuyé par
une équipe de la première chaîne de
télévision en russe la chaîne est à TIC
Russia hein regardez
ces règles mais là je suis sûr que c'est
un cas pas
avant on n'avait pas le droit mais
aujourd'hui on peut parce qu'on combat
pour notre patrie et contre les
fascistes
alors voilà celui-ci c'est de ma part
non j'ai essayé c'est lourd
on va remettre un peu de fioul et on
remet ça
alors effectivement ce qu'il fait est
interdit par l'éthique journalistique
sur un autre point de la ligne de front
à Kerson ville annexée par la Russie
puis reprise par l'armée ukrainienne au
lendemain de cette attaque de drone sur
le Kremlin ce ne sont pas des fascistes
mais bien des civils qui ont péri des
frappes russes tombé sur un centre
commercial et une gare elles font au
moins 23 morts et 46 blessés accusant
les terroristes et les nazis de Kiev
d'attaquer la Russie les chaînes de
télévision russe ne mentionnent jamais
le fait que leur propre bombardement
font sans cesse des victimes parmi les
civils Ukrainiens de cette frappe si les
chaînes de télévision russe n'ont pas
non plus dis un mot c'était la chronique
vu de Russie par Elena holochine merci
beaucoup Elena vous retrouve bien sûr
vendredi prochain pour le nouveau numéro
de vue de Russie merci infiniment la
semaine prochaine